The answer is the second and the third I think are good reasons. The first one
is not a good reason. Normally, shorter code is better than longer code. The
exception is if you get paid by the line, in which case you might prefer longer
code. This is why it's a bad policy to pay programmers by the line of code. The
second reason, errors are actually a good thing. We much prefer to get an error
than to get unexpected behavior. In this case, well, if we use the wrong name,
we probably would have got the behavior we wanted. But, in general we want to
program defensively, under the belief that usually it's better to get an error
than get an incorrect result. Of course, this depends a lot on what we're doing,
and often it may be better to write code in such a way that the program survives
and keeps going instead of stopping with an error. So this is only usually true,
but it's always a good idea to program defensively. The third answer's
definitely true. One of our main goals as a programmer should be to make our
code readable and maintainable. This means it's easy for someone else to
understand what we're doing, and to make changes in the code without breaking
things. This is sometimes in conflict with making code concise. We do would want
our code to be short, and generally the shorter the code the better, except
where making the code short makes it harder and harder for someone to
understand. As a general guideline If you're writing code that you think, if you
came back to it a week later, you wouldn't understand what it does, that's
probably a bad idea. Much better to write the code in the simpler slightly
longer way, than to do something really clever to make it short.